for the first time in screen history a
special interval will be provided during
the running of this picture for
refunding your admission if you're
unable to stand the almost unbearable
suspense the almost paralyzing shock of
homicidal
if homicide is your hobby may I
recommend a surgical knife for a nice
clean quiet murder I'm William castle
and this wheelchair is just to rest my
tired nerves after producing a picture
like this one we are so sure you will
find it such a shocking and startling
experience that we are offering a
money-back guarantee when you come to
see homicidal at the height of the
suspense there will be a fright break an
interval during which you can quiet your
nerves if you are too frightened to see
the end of the picture you're a full
admission price will be refunded time to
go downstairs now got a date to carve a
corpse
you